nous sommes 7 3 milliards sur terre on
dénombre 3 7 milliards d'internautes et
parmi eux 87 % utilisent les réseaux
sociaux chaque mois certains les
utilisent pour suivre l'actualité
d'autres pour jouer à kandy crush ou
bien rechercher un ami d'enfance qu'ils
avaient perdue mois facebook m'a permis
de retrouver ma famille biologique
je m'appelle gabriela j'ai 20 ans et
voici mon histoire je suis né en 1995 à
bogota en colombie
j'ai quatre mois après la naissance
était adopté par un couple franco
colombien j'ai connu une enfance
paisible avec l'arrivée d'un petit frère
besoin plus tard on a une complicité
folle je fais partie des enfants adoptés
chanceux je n'ai ni perdu ma double
culture ni perdu ma langue natale
ma mère adoptive et en colombienne vous
vous êtes aussi sied demandé à qu'est-ce
que vous ressembliez le plus quand vous
étiez petit et si vous n'y pensiez pas
il y avait forcément un ami bienveillant
ou bien le boulanger au point de la rue
pour chercher cette ressemblance avec
vos parents alors il vous suffisait de
monter dans le grenier de plonger une
heure ou de votre nez dans les albums
photo de famille pour y trouver la
réponse vers mes dix ans j'ai assisté à
mon premier cours de sciences et vie de
la terre
on étudie à l'hérédité ma voisine de
droite me disais moi j'ai les cheveux de
ma mère et mon voisin de gauche je me
disais ma moi j'ai la couleur des yeux
mon père et ce soir là je suis rentré
chez moi et j'ai demandé à ma mère
adoptive et moi acquiesce que je
ressemble ce sont des questions que je
me suis posée étant petit et auquel je
n'ai des réponses que la majorité
la législation colombienne oblige à
attendre la majorité pour entamer ses
recherches
j'ai alors attendu patiemment mes 18 ans
qui sont arrivés très vite je me
rappelle
tous mes amis n'avaient qu'une hâte
sortir pour la première fois en boîte
passer leur permis
moi je ne pensais qu'à une seule chose
retrouver ma famille biologique
j'ai commencé comme beaucoup d'enfants
adoptés en contactant les services
sociaux colombien et l'institution de
laquelle je venais un mois après deux
jours avant noël j'ai reçu un dossier un
dossier de huit pages ce dossier relaté
ma naissance mon passé et il y avait
d'identité de ma mère biologique
je vous laisse imaginer notre noël cette
année là j'avais quelques réponses mais
d'autres questions naissait à quoi
ressemble et elle ma raison me disait de
ne pas continuer ses recherches car
j'allais chamboulé ma vie ainsi que mes
études de droit
mais mon coeur me disais qu'une seule
chose qu'attends tu fonces vous vous en
doutez la curiosité a eu raison de moi
et j'ai continué ses recherches
j'ai alors recontacté les services
sociaux colombien si certains d'entre
vous pensent que l'administration
française est lente
n'allez pas en colombie a ajouté il est
7 heures de décalage horaire les minutes
étaient des heures les heurts étaient
des jours deux mois plus tard je n'avais
toujours pas de nouvelles des services
sociaux colombien
je pense alors aux autres moyens que
j'avais pour retrouver ma famille
biologique
j'avais un nom un prénom une ville et un
âge approximatif
je pense alors à facebook mais ça me
paraissait tellement fou de retrouver ma
mère biologique sur facebook
et pourtant je les fais j'ai parcouru
pendant une semaine les profils et j'ai
fini par trouver un profil qui
correspondait voilà diana elle a 36 ans
aujourd'hui
merci facebook mais qu'est ce que
j'allais faire maintenant
j'avais se profile sous les yeux en ce
soir de février j'ai été chamboulée
qu'auriez vous fait est-ce que je devais
l'ajouter en ami lui envoyer un poke on
n'est jamais préparé j'ai décidé de
l'ajouter un ami j'étais persuadée
qu'elle allait accepter ou bien
m'envoyer un message
elle ne l'a pas fait car elle n'a pas
tout de suite compris qui est ce que
j'étais
je décide alors de faire preuve de
courage et de lui envoyer un message
je suis né le 29 novembre 1995 en
colombie sous le nom de louise a alors
elle me répond je sais qui tu es et
l'émotion se traduit par les majuscules
elle me dit combien elle a pensé à moi
combien elle a pensé à moi à chaque
anniversaire convient à la regretter sa
décision
je suis dans la retenue et je la laisse
écrire peu à peu les pages de notre
nouvelle histoire
peu à peu nous nous écrivons nous
faisons connaissance
mes premiers mots sont de lui dire que
je vais bien que je viens en france que
j'ai des parents et membres que je fais
des études et qu'elle ne doit pas
regretter sa décision
si facebook n'avait pas existé j'aurais
probablement retrouvé son adresse leur a
adressé une lettre leur ai envoyé là
cette lettre serait peut-être arriver
dans trois semaines ou trois mois ou ne
serait peut-être pas arrivé je découvre
alors que j'ai une soeur d'un an de plus
que moi
ma soeur a découvert mon existence à ses
10 ans ma soeur a grandi et a fait son
adolescence en imaginant une soeur
quelque part sur un autre continent que
le sien vivante ou pas et ne le savais
pas peu à peu nous échangeons à travers
facebook nous faisons connaissance et
plus les semaines passent et plus je
décide de mettre un visage des mots et
une voix sur ces deux personnes qui me
sont chers nous décidons alors de passer
à skype ce même outil qui sert à des
familles et aux amis de garder contact
lorsqu'ils partent en vacances moi je
les utiliser pour entendre la voix de ma
mère biologique et celle de ma soeur
pour la première fois après dix huit ans
de séparation
lors de notre premier échange au skype
avec ma soeur cette rencontre me semble
irréel
nous ne ressemblons nous pleurons nous
rigolons en même temps nous cherchons
une ressemblance physique nous comparons
la femme de nos yeux nourrir nous sommes
heureuses de pouvoir profiter de
l'opportunité que nous offre la vie
nous retrouver j'entends la voix de
diana pour la première fois je met enfin
un visage et une voix sur cette femme
qui m'a porté pendant neuf mois au fil
des skype j'entreprends de partir en
colombie pour les rencontrer j'organise
ce voyage avec mes parents adoptifs
nous cherchons ensemble l'endroit le
plus propice pour rencontrer diana nous
pensons alors un institution de laquelle
je viens c'était une manière de clore ce
mauvais chapitre pour elle sur de belles
retrouvailles
je décide de faire ce voyage seul car
c'est une capture nom personnel
le jour du départ et les onze heures de
vol arrive très vite j'ai déjà fait ce
voyage avec ma famille avec mon frère
nous avions l'habitude de manger tout ce
qui est gratuit dans l'avion de regarder
tous les chemins possibles et de dormir
je passe les onze heures de vol sans
manger sans regarder ce film et je
réfléchis
j'essaye d'imaginer cette première
rencontre avec diana avant de partir
j'avais organisé mon voyage et les
quelques premiers jours comme j'aime le
faire et le jour de ma rencontre avec
diana est arrivé très vite
ce matin là je me réveille tôt je vais
l'institution plutôt pour rencontrer un
psychologue et roncq on est préparé
cette rencontre avec diana je vous
laisse imaginer un établissement de
trois étages avec de vastes couloirs et
sur ses vestes de couleur il y avait des
cadres dans ses cadres il y avait une
vingtaine de photos aucune été dupliquée
quelle était la probabilité pour qu'en
sortant du bureau du psychologue un
cadre matière l'oeil une photo matière
l'oeil que cette photo soit celle d'un
jeune couple 18 ans auparavant avec un
bébé de quatre mois dans leurs bras une
infime probabilité et pourtant c'est
arrivé alors quelques minutes plus tard
j'allais être en compagnie de la femme
qui est à l'origine de toute cette
histoire et je savais que mes parents à
des milliers de kilomètres de moi ma
compagne avait pensé à moi je devais
retrouver diana dans la salle dans
laquelle mes parents ont reçu cette fois
ci
devait bel et bien affronter je ne
pouvais pas je ne pouvais pas m'en des
filets grâce à une mauvaise connexion
internet
diana était face à moi elle souriait
elle était belle et nous étions sereine
de nous retrouver
on n'est jamais préparé à une rencontre
avec sa mère biologique on ne sait pas
s'il faut lui serrer la main lui faire
la bise ou bien la prendre dans nos bras
tout s'est fait très naturellement et
ses premiers mots ont été tués a les
mêmes yeux que le jour où je t'ai laissé
j'étais face à une inconnue et pourtant
je lui devais la vie alors nous nous
sommes assises et nous avons parlé nous
avons fait connaissance et nous avons
parlé de notre passé commun
le jour où je rencontre ma soeur pour la
première fois nous devenons tout de
suite l'inséparable nous rigolons il ya
une complicité et nous passons des
heures et des heures à nous raconter nos
18 ans nos premiers amours nos premières
expériences nos premiers voyages et je
fais à nouveau face un choc culturel
ma soeur a 21 ans et elle a déjà deux
enfants mon voyage en colombie se passe
très vite je fais connaissance avec ma
nouvelle famille
même si ma famille adoptive me manque
aujourd'hui et besoin après mon voyage
en colombie
j'apprends le français à ma soeur dont
le but de la faire venir en europe et je
donnais un nouveau départ et je garde de
très bons contacts avec diana grâce à
internet
de nos jours nous sommes beaucoup à
saisir l'opportunité des réseaux sociaux
pour retrouver un monde qui nous est
cher lorena j'affine sont deux soeurs
colombienne adoptée par deux familles
différentes
elles ont perdu leurs parents
biologiques lors d'une avalanche de boue
en colombie qui a fait des centaines de
morts elles se sont retrouvées
trente ans après leur disparition grâce
à une vidéo facebook qui a été partagé
par l'une d'elles dans le but de
retrouver sa soeur depuis la naissance
des réseaux sociaux on assiste à des
mouvements notamment un mouvement social
qui est née c'est celui des enfants nés
sous x
des centaines et des centaines d'enfants
recherche leur mère biologique
grâce à facebook et comme moi ils
veulent retrouver leurs origines
savoir d'où ils viennent connaître leur
mère biologique
mais à ce que les mères biologiques
est ce que les mères biologiques qui ont
accouché sous x réussiront à garder cet
anonymat juridique je m'attelle à la
rédaction d'un livre depuis deux ans et
dans mon livre je cherche à remettre en
cause et les préjugés que l'on est
souvent sur l'adoption
non ce n'est pas un acte de charité non
ce n'est pas un acte qui devrait
susciter que du malaise au contraire je
n'ai pas peur de dire que je suis le
fruit de deux destins d'amour c'est la
preuve d'amour je suis ici également
pour témoigner de la magie des réseaux
sociaux
cet outil ne traite pas que des données
ni des calculs il sert à se faire
affaire se recroiser des chemins que la
vie à les séparer
merci